hallo YouTube jazz lovers in my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
15th episode of my chest strap series
and this episode I am going to show you
an interesting trap in the Queens gambit
declined exchange variation from the
white perspective
now the qgd exchange variations arises
after the water d4 d5 c4 e6 Knight to c3
Knight to f6 and now white exchange in
the center that is see cactus defy and
ecaptions' defy the mainline goes as
follows
white continue here with the Bishop to
g5 pinning that night thus pressurizing
the d5 square so black breaks the pin
with the move Bishop to e7 afterwards
white will continue with the move III
now here there are two ways black can
follow the main line the most popular
move in this situation is c6 but in this
game black continue with the MU Castle
on the Kings side and after that white
has to play this important move Bishop
to d3 which has an important point it is
stopping Bishop to fi idea by black and
Bishop to g4 is not a good move the
simple reason is after Queen to b3 white
is attacking to sports and it's not easy
for black to defend both the locations
so in other words black is forced to
play here Knight B to d7 afterwards the
mainline continue with the moon Queen to
c2 c6 Knight to f3 and rook to e8 blacks
last move has two distinct ideas number
one it faciliate the square for either
bishop or the knight and the second
modern idea is in some line it allow
Knight to e4 more now just to illustrate
my point in one game while champion
magnus carlsen was facing Dutch Grand
Master van wheelie where when will he
continue here with the MU h3 so his idea
is to preserve the dark square bishop
but here it calls him give him this
ultimate chalk light too
for obviously this is a pawn sacrifice
which white accept it after Bishop
captures eform and after that black has
to capture on the e4 Kiley note Bishop
captures G fuh is not possible the
simple reason is after Bishop captures
at 7 check came to h8 and Bishop back to
the d3 white is a clear pawn up so
that's why at this position black has to
capture this bishop on the e4 but after
that White will continue with the move
Knight courtesy form it's obvious that
white is a pawn up but Carlsen he
reveals his nasty idea he played Queen
check and if white wants retain any
advantage White has to play the Moon
King to have fun and materially speaking
white is upon up but White King is
clearly misplaced and that is more than
enough compensation for the black in
fact it is justified as council went on
to win this game so it is very obvious
there h3 allow Knight to e4 so that's
why why it has to castle at this point
after that the main move over here is
Knight method now in this modern world
where theories keep changing in every
few days it's hard to cope up with the
theory and especially at club level you
are not going to see most players
playing the theoretical line so for
example if even though let's say black
knows this stuff after Knight to f8 he
has to face the minority to attack by
white that is b4 b5 and it's not easy to
play as a black so as I mentioned
earlier the second and most popular idea
by the black over here is they want to
prolong the night on the e4 and this is
where our trap lies now funny thing is
Knight to e4 at this point is not
possible even though it has been played
by 23 players whose average rating are
2200 Plus here white can simply capture
this night and after pawn captures and
Knight captures black doesn't have the
check which we have seen in the Magnus
Carlsen game so in such a situation
White has no issues
so one may think okay if Knight to e4 is
not possible
how about I'll play at six first so now
if the bishop goes to the s4 that light
to e4 is indeed possible so white is
forced to play Bishop to f4 afterwards
black can play this move Knight to h5
which on the surface looks so good
because it's nabbing the bishop pair
which will give a great advantage to the
black in the endgame well everything
looks so perfect except black is falling
into the white trap it is very hard to
see as from the black perspective and
that's why this trap has been occurred
116 times where black players average
yellow is more than 2300 very surprising
but it is true before I move on I like
you to pause this video and find out
what is the trap here okay I hope you
find this wonderful move boom well what
is a pawn up and the problem over here
is black cannot take this night because
after Bishop to c7
black Queen is a goner the best lines
are just over here is Knight captures f4
but after that but can capture this
Knight and remain a solid pawn up and
with accurate play this is almost a
decisive advantage so this is a nice and
a cute trap in the qgd exchange
variation so if you are a white player
then you certainly have to look out for
it and if you are playing from the black
perspective then you should certainly
avoid it well thank you for watching
this video feel free to like subscribe
and comment on my video and I'll meet
you in my next episode very soon bye and
take care
so the only reply left is to take the
ball by unperson but now comes complete
cue
trap which is Bishop to f5 and if you
count the pieces right now black is a
piece off but believe it or not this is
exactly why tones